[Music]
what's different about entrepreneurship
than rap and sports is when you say
you're a rapper someone's like are a rap
and then if you suck everyone's like oh
you suck
you know and when you say you're a
basketball player people like at the
YMCA or or going to the league the one
thing I love about entrepreneurship is
its binary either you're gonna win or
you're gonna lose
you know being a businessman or woman
wasn't cool in 1992 and was Bill Gates
you know like a [ __ ] nerd you know
like so so now that everybody wants to
put entrepreneurship in their Instagram
profile and that's cool in the club that
is just bizarro world but that's also
done what sports and wrapping you has
which is everybody wishes they are and
what's different about entrepreneurship
than wrap and sports is when you say
you're a rapper someone's like are a rap
and then if you suck everyone's like oh
you suck you know and when you say
you're a basketball player people like
at the YMCA or or going to the league
but when somebody now says they're an
entrepreneur it's just accepted and we
we haven't matured into are you a
successful entrepreneur or a wannabe
entrepreneur and I you know to be very
frank I'm concerned about it because I
think the one thing I love about
entrepreneurship is its binary either
you're gonna win or you're gonna lose
and I think that there's a lot of people
right now that are not built with
dealing with the emotional baggage that
comes along with a public loss and so I
spent a lot of time with young
entrepreneurs around the mentality of
like when you lose you know are you
ready to take that ridicule and what are
you gonna do the the greatest reason I
believe that we're living through such
fake entrepreneurship right now is not
only is there an enormous amount of
capital in play for these twenty to
twenty five year olds but they're the
generation you know that was parented in
a way that tried to eliminate losses
from the ecosystem I mean this is the
generation of eighth-place trophies
right this is you know my favorite thing
that's going on in society right now is
forty-five to sixty year olds you know
clowning on Millennials and making fun
of them and I keep looking at them and I
keeps reminding them that you parented
these Kinison everybody gets a trophy
right yeah I mean and so you know we've
demonized to these kids losing I loved
losing like micro losing especially more
the macro losing is incredibly
motivating them you know I mean there's
nothing more fun than losing
regular-season games you know you learn
from them you know come the playoffs
you'd like to build on that but yeah I
mean I think adversity is the foundation
of success being born in the Soviet
Union living in a studio apartment with
a family members when I was a kid going
on one-and-a-half vacations my entire
childhood my parents buying me nothing
because they didn't have like the money
nor the mindset to do that for me is
fundamentally the reason I'm successful
at entrepreneurship I'm not scared of
anything nor do I care about anybody
else's judgment which allows me to
navigate very quickly and my losses are
my losses and my wins are my wins and
they both feel the same when I hear the
accolades or when I get razzed I
basically can't hear them I'm just so in
love with the process and that's and
that's what getting up off the floor is
you had no choice you just it's in your
DNA to want to play I'm wondering what's
the message to a company that that
doesn't have innovation as a core part
of their business how do they respond by
letting themselves die but what do they
do that don't want to die in a bate and
how do they do that what's the secret by
looking at the leader of the company in
the mirror and see if she or he is
capable of innovating everything stems
from the top
if you run if you have a company run by
somebody who right now is sitting and
saying well I'm retiring in 18 months
and I don't give a [ __ ] about innovation
you're in trouble for not talented
enough to know how to innovate like you
nobody pays number ones hire a CMO and
say you figure it out but they don't
even know how to judge it how are you a
CEO in 2019 and don't spend a hundred
hours to educate yourself on how modern
communication works so that you can
judge it within your own organization
Gary I didn't grow up with this stuff
you didn't grow up driving you figured
it out like I know you didn't grow up
with it but it is your job to it's
required of you to know how to run your
business and to me how your business
markets and communicates is as important
as you knowing how to run the finances
of your company it's just that some
people don't want to put in the work to
get updated on the new platforms and the
new world and that's to their peril the
advice that I think will play for
everybody in the room regardless of what
you do including if like you're the PTA
president or thinking about running for
local office like I have no idea what
you want to do professionally or
personally but the one thing that has
been tried and true and I keep things
extremely simple is you have to reverse
engineer the audience you're trying to
reach and you have to tell them
something that brings them value not you
value every single person here that
isn't power to do so needs to go spend
the next hundred days having phone calls
having dinner having breakfast having
drinks with every one of their customers
and they need to listen to what they
care about and they need to go back to
the pad and cook that meal that's all I
do
I read my comments you know left and
right like you know I was just talking
to CMO prepping you know you were until
you guys were wrapping up and she's like
are you always like this on your phone
and I was laughing what I was doing I
was reading comments
because the qualitative feedback is the
insight I need for the next innovation
the amount of people who hope their
customers like what they are doing or
they're trying to force their customers
to like what they want to sell is
fascinating for me to watch you talked
about this is that people who are
driving down the culture of a business
should be they should be there sir I
wish most businesses weren't to
documenting in coach what most
businesses are doing is heralds a dick
but his numbers are remarkable yeah
that's what's really happening that's
what I'm referring to that if you've got
somebody who's driving top-line revenue
or as she or he is rushing their numbers
what most companies are doing is they're
looking at surface level then I go if we
fire Carol we're gonna lose those three
accounts cuz she's so wired and they're
what they don't realize is the hidden
lost revenue that's happening with Carol
or Harold destroying the culture and
completely messing up the continuity and
speed of the backroom so what do you do
from your point of view what do you do
if you had you have someone who's really
kicking ass bringing the numbers in and
they're just they're a jerk what are you
doing what I do and one one man's point
of view is I sit them down
I looked up dead at the vase and I say
you think I'm joking because you're
delivering but I'm not joking and if you
can't be a good human being I'm going to
fire your face that's pretty right Barry
that's what I do and I do it and I do it
you know I'm a big shot on stage now and
I'm acting tough I do it I do it in a
conversation I'm like look I'm not
kidding like I know you don't believe me
because you've worked in other places
that value dollars and I value dollars I
just value slow dives right so when you
deliver on culture the buy-in and the
macro is remarkable and what it does for
the business is extraordinary I'm a I'm
a pot committed buyer of this
that you have to fire the best
performers that are destroying your
culture
[Music]
you